hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sleep and dawn now this
is a horror game set inside of a
procedurally generated maze and at first
I thought it was just single-player but
apparently you can play with up to three
of your friends for a four-player horror
experience but before I do that I'm
gonna play the single-player and if it's
too difficult then I'm gonna ask my
friends to join me in a later episode if
it's good enough if it's not good then
it's it's fine but I actually read up on
the multiplayer okay I am very sorry for
whatever I've done whoa help your
wounded friends I was just saying I
would have gotten my friends out here
oh oh oh do not make hit noise hit him
hit him with a stick use the light keep
watching or do not try to oh I'm
supposed to be pretty I got a hit and
stick yeah ahead and stick Oh
dodged it three times I don't know what
you want me to dodge but it's not gonna
work they can see you who is they they
you can see me god damn it
alright anyway I guess that's about this
winky face there to dry but you have to
find them and activate the lever after
the levers find the exit
alright wait what down up up down Oh
like I get to two lepers man whoa
alright okay then
well I got it I got to find two right
picked up an item picked up an item I'm
guessing it's in if you were playing for
players you could have a multiple
options oh can I draw please telling me
it's so oh just an X though oh come on
Oh fine alright fine then okay
all right I'm ready I think you very
bright
what's my bag of smoke Oh
it's bag of rocks tobacco Rock says I
should have known
oh hi okay all right I don't know what
the big bombs all about hey how's it
going hi Fred oh I'm dead I by him
already dead that didn't go well at all
I'm gonna try that again something tells
me I'm gonna need friends with this one
all right get up get up come on get up
we got to go hurry all right let's see
what we got
get my head and stick him with that okay
I think that was that guy avoid uh-huh
see I didn't I didn't look for that one
I didn't see that I would have known if
I had seen a void is [ __ ] there all
right okay let's do this Leroy jam oh
it's Rando all right is Rando all right
forgot I've forgotten everything
instantaneously I've forgotten
everything and I got a bad feeling about
this okay Oh squooshy all right oh whoa
hey whoa okay you know I ain't gonna go
near that yeesh okay let me just try the
other way first yeah the big mannequin
can go bone himself oh god no I am the
one that has to bone the big mannequin
all right well is he the Hitty stick man
or is he the rock thing is that what it
is I don't remember quite correctly oh
boy where you at buddy there you are
okay all right I don't like that but
okay
I do party okay I hate that oh I hate
that
yeah don't don't do anything don't do
anything okay
all right you still there okay all right
yeah squishy hey hey who's over there
huh whoa no I don't like it okay all
right okay all right is that a dead end
is that a dead end oh of course I just
had to hit an enemy first thing out of
the gate in the first round I kind of
been learning is Oh what is that that's
new
all right McDonald's is nearby great
can't wait for that like why does it
sound like someone's walking behind me
it does that thing where the it puts the
footsteps just behind you and I don't
like that
or either behind you I'm killing time
geez Oh what if you well if this isn't
the way to go then which was whoa
that looked like a face with him where
the hell am I supposed to go Hey aah
light light you need light right you
supposed to get light I don't like this
oh you want a rock okay rock rock for
you
oh no which way did you come from lady
which way did you come from cuz I'm
about to punch you in your face yeah
whoa ah I saw that well it's a bird okay
it's fine everybody calm down some bird
yeah hey hey hey hey hey alright I saw a
lady are you lady
this might be the way I came in from not
a lady
don't mind my squashing I'm just
naturally squooshy person Rock I didn't
need to dodge now she's gonna turn
around why did I do that that was really
dumb of me let's go in again let's do it
baby I'll turn down easy and see if I
fail also which I will definitely well
projects reduces a time limit oh I get
it
the that sound is me I'm in like limbo
or something like that yeah
oh and I should use the chalk to mark
where I beam I can't i-i've been here
why what is you I don't like that what
are you doing what are you doing what
are you doing what are you doing it what
are you what is that what is that what
is that what is that what is that oh
that's not my footsteps I thought this
was supposed to be easier okay nothing
over here boy okay who's there
okay rubbish maybe I should read the
instructions a little bit better
hey look a dark dank tunnel and my dank
I mean literally it's pretty green in
air whoa
no oh that's just a running away hole
I'm getting flashbacks from vanish I
don't know why but I am oh gotta get in
hidey-hole boopadoo de doodle-do alright
okay alright let me mark this down
voodoo Sookie okay got that doing pretty
decently I'd say I'd say I'd say but I'd
be wrong but I'm gonna say it okay
hey I know how to do this I know what
I'm doing it oh I definitely know what
I'm alive I'm alive
oh oh oh this is a Dodge three times guy
think it might be
Wow Oh God okay all right okay all right
okay all right didn't scare me at all
Oh didn't scare me I know how to beat
you maybe we'll see about that hmm
oh god damn it of course all right I
don't even know what one of these levers
look like I came from this way but I'm
not gonna mark it off yet is deaded all
right this is all dead end B not you not
you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
we're fine
whoa hey how about a rock over there you
were going that why did I do I keep
there we're going that way
they've done that well that way thank
you oh I thought things are supposed to
be easier this is this is anything but
if anything is more more not easier all
right I came from this way no not a rock
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah what is
that
was that oh is that laser man hey nice
eyeballs oh you do what what Oh
alright okay weird a little weird
I will admit a little whoa oh oh hey
Rach nope nope nope no no you didn't see
nothing
whoo that vine is wrigley something
tells me I don't want to die to that
lady
god damn and I have to go that way all
right well I'm running out of time
anyway so death is common
that's a be coming round the mountain
whoa
it's hard to tell where you're looking
buddy can you uh oh thank you thank you
thank you thank you yeah I think I got
dripped on drupe dummy okay this thing
there's something over there uh do I
want to risk going by this thing I do I
really do you know I do I do
okay yeah I switch switch swatch No
okay well I'm boned oh okay all right
okay whoa whoa whoa whoa I see something
on the top of that we're oh I see
something on the top of that wall I
don't know
Oh backing no way backing away oh hey
I'll hit you with a stick I'll hit you
oh oh
crap crap monster crap my sir crab
monster general goddammit it damn god
damn damn I'll hit you with a stick so
many sticks stick up your butt hello
lady would you like and stick up your
butt Rock what is that all about what is
that all about what are you okay it got
weird you know it was scary and then it
got really weird okay okay so uh that is
uh that is all the time I got for sleepy
done sleeping dawn I think I want to
play this with uh with my buddies and I
think it'll be super cool so let me know
if you want to see that down in the
comments below I'll try to get that in
order soon and let me know what you
think of this game I'll provide a link
to it in the description as always and
thanks again for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]